let's get right into it the story of the
first couple weeks of the NBA season in
your estimation would be what Chris oh
wow
a few storylines or what is how is the
Westbrook Hardin experiment working out
LeBron mister triple-double King I think
those you know uh two storylines and of
course going to State Warriors with
being hit with so many injuries I mean I
cannot believe they are you know
obviously there's a reason why but two
and nine Chris that is unbelievable and
open up your new facility with this
first couple weeks they must be beside
themselves right now yeah and first of
all you know I picked them not to make
the playoffs this year so I didn't have
high expectations and without klay
Thompson I don't think that they had
enough and in the West is tough but I
also felt that this would just be a year
that they just you know take off get
some rest in that next year with that
same team they could come back and be
very dominant but no one expected to see
these injuries but man you can't in my
opinion you can't live without clay the
most underrated player in the game
because he plays with such a great
player defensively he guards the best
players offensively he keeps it hot even
when he's in a streak and I just felt
you can't keep that going and so when
you look at what the Lakers have done
and even with the white Howard how he's
been playing ad and of course LeBron
what he's been doing is just it's just
incredible and I really like seeing the
body language of the energy of the
Lakers as well you can tell that they're
playing for something and hopefully I
have Denver tonight and I want to see
Denver take that up because I think that
Denver should have the expectations that
we put on other teams remember how we
said the lob cities should win more and
we said other teams well Denver we're
letting off the hook because the market
they're in but they should be that team
on the radar as well with that body
language but I'll tell you what it's
been a fun season so far he's only gonna
get better yeah I mean the Nuggets have
won seven of their first ten they're
taking on the Brooklyn Nets tonight try
young lit them up the other night though
holy crap that kid is really born wrong
right how about rayon I mean so many
people said well he's not this he's not
that and I got the double-team on late
in his college career and right now he's
showing this thing
part of the new MBA the new MBA adjust
flame throwers out there and he's fun
he's fun to watch and I tell you what he
is an excellent offensive player and he
can shoot the three from anywhere but
what I'm impressed about is that he just
as good of a passer
I think he's gonna lead the league in
assists in a couple of years and uh he's
fun to watch have you ever given a
five-second long stare down at a bench
after making a shot or a dunk Chris have
you ever done that what he did the other
night
no I've done that just period I didn't
even have to school and there's somebody
to get up because I wanted to I had
energy I was ready to go right but they
went in this new league man that's and
you know this is the thing too and this
is something for the fans to watch this
really fun right whenever a player gets
the ball in the corner and he looks back
at the bench I mean you see this maybe
once a game because the bench is talking
so much junk to him while he's shooting
the ball so you gotta realize guys can
stand up guys go huh well that's awful
no I let him shoot all day like guys are
really saying a lot of stuff that we
can't hear and I gave nice versions of
it and so when you hit that out the
corner and you still like you have seven
under other defenders behind you yeah
you know because you can't see him and
you got to let them know I heard you and
hopefully you saw what I do well it's
funny Chris as you were telling that
story we were showing the Trey young
shot over and over again I do see a
couple of Gabby Denver Nuggets during
that shot I did see some lip flap from
their bench
oh yeah anybody standing up especially
like the guys in the corner of his two
or three guys standing up and always
tell that they are the ones and trust me
that's their job because I've seemed to
make a lot of guys miss shots or getting
their heads but the only thing is that
you have a cold-blooded killer not one
thing is funny is when Larry Bird played
against the Atlanta Hawks they weren't I
think he had 60 in a game they weren't
behind him yelling at him they were
behind him giving each other five like I
can't believe he's doing this and so and
and I would have find all of them even
though I would agree with the one
offense I would have fined all them but
you get a lot of reactions from the
[ __ ] from the corner 300 that's myself
much fun Chris forever here on the Rich
Eisen show I got another story for you
there's certainly wouldn't nobody saw
coming how about the eight and three
Toronto Raptors how about that
how about a singular what do you think
is that sustainable what do you think
you well it's the East Coast I do know I
don't know if they're sustainable at
that level but I do think them winning
is sustainable especially when you have
guys that like bands leading others that
have already proven that they're some of
the toughest guys into the sea ahkam
what he's done after signing that machs
extension the raise in his game to a
level you have to give you know coach
Nick nurse a lot of credit one because
he gives the previous regime a lot of
credit for setting the tone there
defensively but he holds the guard to a
high standard and then again in the East
is has something left to be desired with
competition from one through eight but I
do expect to Ron tell there's no reason
they shouldn't be a top four team and
what they've done on the West Coast
playing is just so impressive to me
getting big wins on the road and show
man they're doing that thing got to get
them a lot of credit Chris Webber here
on the Rich Eisen show okay and then
you've got again Brooklyn and Denver
tonight at in Denver's at you and Marv
you and marvelous and I can I'm hanging
out with the voice please send him my
best gosh honestly I do this job because
in part of him there's no I tell him
that every time and I probably embarrass
him every single time I do it and then
the first part of the double header is
Dallas at New York I don't care I'll
I'll just come out and say I think what
what this is obvious what we're okay
dope that's being run on phys Dale here
III don't think it's fair at all to lay
a two and nine start at this man's feet
when they go over in free agency and
phys Dale in my mind was the guy that
gave the Knicks any amount of hope of
attracting anybody in free agency I put
that at your feet and asked you if I'm
accurate yeah hundred percent accurate
when I started to hear that I was being
blamed the first thing I thought of was
that's why if I could have talked to him
I would've told him don't take the job
you know my father used to say one
mess-up kills a million hunt data boys
you know and so it's funny how the whole
narrative has changed when you had guys
like LeBron and D Wade and all the guys
that he helped I don't say develop but
he was that assisting coach too
really vouching Foreman you know when
players really like a coach especially
one that's demanding it speaks a lot to
their communication their passion the
fact that they don't take it personal
and so now that the narrative has
changed it's just um it's something
really I when I heard it I was like I
know this isn't real I just putting this
out here to get fielders to see the
response but I think it's unfair to fit
in and then you feel you feel bad for
that because in this league you know you
can either be a coaster Keith kin
chances and come here okay coach your
whole time but maybe be part of some
groups that keeps you around or you
could have a lot of potential have that
one shot and because it's not a stable
environment never get another shot I
don't think he'll be at that group but
you just you just you just never know
you just never know
so what do we expect out of Paul George
who's returning tonight while you are on
the air what do you got for me on this
front Oh what do I expect out apologize
I expect defense I expect him to have
fun I think he's in an environment where
I didn't build a package for this last
week but I call them the young hyenas
because the Clippers they don't have big
guys they don't have you know overly
strong guys or all this other stuff but
they hunt in packs and they have the
energy we just hear them laughing and
whooping up and causing hysteria
wherever they're going they take the
food of the larger predators like lions
and others because they're in Houston so
I think he's going to be part of that
pack and we're gonna see one of the best
defensive teams especially perimeter
lies that we've seen and that's why I
trust the Clippers from Doc Rivers and
trust means to go out and play as hard
as you can give it all you got and have
an honest chance because I trust their
effort every night I mean this is a team
that could probably shoot under 40% in a
big game and still maybe win by 10 or 12
because of their my defensive intensity
so that's why I believe I'm not
necessary for anything sexy and I know
Kawhi comes over and he's great but if
she didn't play defense the way that he
did Beverly didn't play my trans Harrell
didn't play defense Lou coming off the
bench to me they have the perfect storm
of humble personalities that are
aggressive at the same time and in guys
who know their role and encourage others
to do that all
Clippers are really fun to watch then
again it's not about back into the back
to back and so far we've seen Kauai load
managed during those spots auto I'm
assuming we might see him both tonight
were you ever load managed Chris Webber
you know that's such a tricky discussion
I wasn't and I still even though I've
had a really great long career I feel
that it would have been improved with
low management but that's so many
factors for instance low management can
also be practiced like I played in the
era where unfortunately practice and we
all made fun of AI for saying this but
practice was just as important as the
games and that's not true
it's just it's just natural especially
when you're a professional so let's just
take I don't know a quarterback and
let's say it's a veteran quarterback we
didn't care about drew Brees practices
when we came back I said now my fingers
helped yeah I didn't throw this much
this week but don't work because he
knows those plays he's not gonna do
Brees not gonna get better from practice
you're gonna get better in the still
more he's going to get better sitting
down listening and singing what the game
plan is but out there physically
exerting and injuries and things like
that a three hour practice of pressing I
mean coaching was really antiquated in
our style in the last 20 years and I do
think we have to look at data however
the tickets decedent holders the ticket
season for season ticket holders the TV
audience we deserve to see these games
and so I think there's a way with
scheduling especially on national TV
night the NBA can control the schedule
they say no back to backs if you have a
ESPN game on Wednesday no back to backs
if you have a Turner game on Wednesday
because I'm on Thursday because you want
these players to play so if it is a load
management I think that the lead can
help by lightening the load so that you
don't have to lighten the load on game
nights they've already done that by
taking away so many back to backs
they've done that by mentioning the time
that you come back after all-star game
so the league is doing everything they
can and now I think they need to dress
that with the national TV schedule hey
let's just not have the Clippers play
Wednesday and Thursday back-to-back so
ESPN can get their audience and Turner
can get
you know I mean it's ways to go about it
and I hope that um a little addressed
and and all the happier the fans be
better and happier what do you think
Chris Webber though of the theory that
Earl Watson put out on Twitter and
LeBron echoed in a conversation with
Yahoo that the load management really
needs to be managed at the AAU level
that youth travel basketball teams are
playing 12 to 15 games a weekend as
Watson tweeted out to keep the monthly
fees validated that that's where the
toll of playing basketball starts and
eventually manifests itself in the NBA
what do you think of that idea Chris I
think there are a hundred percent
correct and that's why the NBA is having
to pay the price for it
and that's why I'm saying the NBA should
worry about the schedule and internet
because until we go back and get them
just let me just say this to parents out
there because I'm a parent I get how
tough it is to be a parent I get how you
want your kids to be in the best
environment but let me tell you guys
something there's no reason that your
child to be playing three games a day
they're not getting better it's no
reason a good coach wouldn't want kids
to play three times a day not three
soccer games a day not three baseball
games today maybe a doubleheader here in
their face but you don't go every day
that's that's the new way so parents
need to understand about Lowell
management's for their kids it's I
understand everybody wants their kids to
be a top five or you know being this
ranking but if you got games you got
game in three games a day means nothing
compared to one really good game dan and
I agree with them you have to lighten
the load that's why we're seeing
injuries being tracked at the NBA that
we haven't had a dis valium before
because even if a guy doesn't play past
a sophomore year guess what he's coming
into the league as if he's had four NBA
seasons under his belt because he's
playing bat mini games and so so the
bran Earl Watson there I mean they live
it there they are so right about it and
I think we have to address that button
but before like they said it's about
money so you know that's going to be
slipping so so before we do I think we
have to address it from top to bottom
and then hopefully go back and make sure
we change change the way that we allow
kids to play in sports and hopefully
that's what some type of governing body
that that has sense and
it's not all about the money before I
let you go Chris forever let's move up
one level to the college level
look who's two-and-oh in Ann Arbor in
his first two games as head coach in the
Michigan Wolverines that would be one
Juwan Howard he's two and oh when are
you making an appearance at Christ how
many how many how long you been coaching
two months I said he is Owen two months
of sleep because I've been texting him
and nothing is good enough and
everything's great you love the kids
there it's game we we text about him
having a big lead and then losing the
lead and I'm like perfect now you can
beat him up in practice and say this but
so it's so fun watching him live his
dream of all as a coach and do such a
great job and I definitely I'd be there
to support my boy very Sean you have a
date in mind you you've got one circled
and I don't I don't I don't which one
like talk and text constantly and so
that's something that's definitely I'm
definitely gonna support him and I think
he even understands that I may have to
come support us beaten Ohio State first
in football and continue return right
over there to him but it's fun watching
him and also you know letting Helmut
establish and and the culture there and
do his thing I really believe that this
is about the long run it's not about any
shortsightedness of me hurrying up and
do this and that I really want to
establish what has there and be
comfortable and and and get his guys
going like they want to and hopefully I
could just come in and just have some
fun and watch them rich I'm I'm looking
I can't tell you how much I'm looking
forward look forward to seeing you there
too and but before Ohio State in
football it's Michigan State this very
weekend you know and I don't I don't
mean again here's oh by the way is was
on my show tomorrow but we got Michigan
State this weekend you know all about
that rivalry personally Chris Webber oh
yeah oh yeah I do and even from being a
fan growing up in Michigan
I remember the Blake Azores and I
remember I was a rising when he started
point guard over Steve Smith before the
basketball team he was all big ten and
enemies all became receiver so I'm a big
Michigan fan
I am Michigan Go clew and I have been a
Michigan State fan and watching growing
up there and so uh yeah I think we'll
handle our business there and we got we
got bigger fish to fry not overlooking
them but we got some pictures to find so
we know we gotta take care of business
this weekend so that we can out so that
we can get to our bigger goals no see
web tell everyone where they can
pre-order your book that's coming out
this fall correct it's coming weeks yeah
actually the data is the change to
February 4th okay just one Amazon right
now you can get it you know you can
pre-order on Amazon but it'll be
everywhere that you can order books um
bars and all those airports everything
like that and I'm really really excited
about it and I think for places that I
played like in Michigan on Sacramento
Detroit even you know other places on
the state that uh hopefully it really
represents those places where all my
time there and how just the people that
have been blessings in my life that I've
been encouraged me sustain me and kept
me going hopefully um they'll see my
appreciation through this book all right
Chris I say hello our caller Jeff and
Detroit said tell him what up dog so I'm
telling you that and then of course my
wife would kill me if I didn't send her
best to you to Chris Webber that's the
only reason why I do your show is
because of her and tell the other guys
you got it take care Chris enjoy the
game tonight with Marv
that's Brooklyn and Denver tonight on
TNT at 10:30 p.m. Eastern tip right
after Dallas in New York porzingis in
Madison Square Garden for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app